florida's becoming the latest u.s
epicenter of the pandemic with a surge
of new infections
from the delta variant there the state
now leads the nation in per capita
hospitalizations
more than 10 200 covet patients are now
hospitalized
that's the most senseless pandemic began
and the state hit its highest single day
total on saturday
they had a reported 21 683 new cases
u.s surgeon general dr vivek murthy
joins us now from miami
to discuss good morning to you it's very
good to see you dr murthy
and despite those numbers in florida the
governor there ron desantis says
there will be no new restrictions and he
will not mandate mask
when you hear that does it concern you
well good morning to you as well and i'm
deeply concerned about what's happening
in florida
and certainly in many parts of our
country with cases rising
and i think what we've seen time and
time again deal with the
with the cloven 19 is that it's going to
throw curve balls at us
delta the delta variant is the latest
curveball and what we have to be ready
to do
is increase our vaccination base while
we are using mitigation measures
including wearing masks that's one of
the reasons the cdc revised
its guidance last week to encourage more
mass usage because we know it's a
powerful way to reduce the spread of the
virus while we're getting vaccination
rates up
well that's the problem when the cdc
revises its mass some people think the
cdc doesn't know what it's doing
the cdc is being accused of
flip-flopping i know
what you all are saying we are updating
the information based on the science
that we have
but i think you have to be very clear
about why wearing a mask
is so important vaccinated or not
vaccinated now
well absolutely so let's talk about that
for a moment the main message from
the cdc's guidance last week was that
regardless of your vaccination status
wearing masks in public indoor settings
is helpful to reduce the spread
of covet especially if you're living in
an area that's got higher substantial
transmission of virus and why is that
mass helpful
because it not only prevents you from
spreading infection to others if you
happen to be
infected but it also protects you from
getting infection
if you happen to be exposed to somebody
else now the good news is that if you
are fully vaccinated
you are in much much much better shape
your risks of dying from covet are
dramatically lower
but being hospitalized from kubota are
also dramatically lower
and your risk of getting sick itself is
also very low if you do happen to have a
breakthrough infection
it's very likely it will be mild or even
asymptomatic but what we learned gail
from the investigation in barnstable
county where there was an outbreak
was it people who are have those
breakthrough infections that small
portion of vaccinated folks
they actually seem to be able to spread
the virus just like someone who's
unvaccinated which is why
the cdc recommended that they also wear
masks and indoor settings for people
like me who are parents
who have unvaccinated children at home
it's an especially helpful
step that we can take to help protect
those of us you know who have family
members who are vulnerable still
dr murphy it's david begno the cdc has
said that the delta variant is as
transmission
transmissible as chickenpox tell us more
about that
well it's a really important point and
this is one of the features of delta
which makes it so concerning
and so different the delta variant seems
to be the most transmissible version of
covid19 that we have seen today
it's why it's rapidly become more than
80 of cases it's why it's driving
our case loads up so high even though
we've got 164 million people in our
country
who are fully vaccinated again they are
in really good shape and most of them
are
doing fine but it's those who are
unvaccinated who are struggling and
they're primarily the ones who are
getting infected
but the data about transmission that can
take place in that small portion of
folks who have breakthrough infections
that was also a key key part of what the
cdc learned in recent days about them to
change guidance
and again this is what covent does is
that the rose curve balls are away we've
got to be able to respond and change
our behavior our guidance you know as a
science as the data changes
but the good news is we have the most
important tool to get through this
pandemic
and that is a vaccine it's saving lives
and it can save
more lives if we can just accelerate our
vaccination rates which is already
happening which is good news
we've just got to keep going is the bite
administration going to ask more
businesses
and schools to mandate vaccinations
well right now what the administration
is doing is he's not telling people
what to do but it's certainly uh taking
action in its own backyard so to speak
so the president recently announced that
there will be uh requirements now for
federal
employees to attest to whether or not
they are vaccinated and if they are not
vaccinated or if they do not want to
test one way or the other
and they will be required to wear masks
in indoor settings
they will be required to test on a
regular basis and they may also not be
able
to travel for federal purposes because
of potentially increased risk of
transmission
so that's those are measures the federal
government is taking as the largest
employer in the country
i think what you are going to see are
more businesses more schools and
certainly more
healthcare systems that are putting
vaccine requirements in place of their
own accord because they're realizing
it's one of the most powerful things
they can do to make the workplace safe
for their employees as well as for their
clients
dr vivek murthy thank you thank you so
much take care